foreign
hey you guys flickers of fear time once
again if you hear some weird noises in
the background it's like wind outside
for some reason it's like really really
windy I don't know why but so sometimes
you can hear it so if you can hear it
that's what that is
so today let's talk about uh this fairly
recent movie right here
so now back when we used to have our AMC
Stubs membership uh which we actually
pretty recently canceled mostly because
well two reasons because I couldn't
really afford it anymore uh and we moved
much farther away from the movie theater
so we found that we were never going so
we were essentially paying for nothing
it was kind of a shame because I did
like to go to the movies but you know
it's just too far to drive and I
couldn't justify paying that much money
when usually you just have to wait a
couple weeks and then the movie will
turn up on VOD anyway
but back when we were still going to the
movies
I swear to God every single time we went
to the theater I saw the trailer for The
Black phone every time I kind of
feel like I saw it so many times
so I feel like the movie was teased
forever
um and then like it just didn't come out
and didn't come out and I'm like what
the hell is going on with that stuff
what ended up happening with it like I
looked it up later
I guess it was first scheduled for wide
release back in like late January of
2022 but then it got pushed back to
February and then it got pushed back to
like June 24th so I think that's when it
finally came out like in summer of 2022
so I think that's probably why I had the
perception that it was like never coming
out because probably we had been going
to the movies like in late 2021 and they
were probably like hyping it then and
then I was just like where the is
this movie like it never came out so
when it finally did come out by the time
summer of 2022 came around you know we'd
already moved out here we weren't really
going to the theater all that often so
you know we just never got around to
seeing it
so then I kind of like forgot about it
until the other day when I was scrolling
through Amazon Prime and I was like oh
hey they added it to streaming I think
it was actually on peacock before that
but you know which I do check sometimes
but I hadn't checked it for whatever
reason but I did see it on Amazon Prime
because I do have a membership to that
so I was like oh I was like kind of
excited about it because honestly the
trailer for this looked pretty good and
it's like usually I like uh blumhouse
and I like Ethan Hawke and you know it
just looked like a cool concept so I was
excited to watch it so as I said this is
a Blum House uh production they were the
pre you know the they were the releasing
company on it and it was directed by
Scott Derrickson who is the man
responsible for the quite excellent
horror films Sinister and The Exorcism
of Emily Rose I think he also did the
first Doctor Strange movie in 2016 and I
think he was also supposed to do the
second one like the Multiverse of
Madness or whatever but like he left
because of creative differences so he
went and like worked on this one which
actually is cool because this seems like
more in his wheelhouse I guess I haven't
seen Doctor Strange I don't know if it's
good like I'm not the Marvel movies are
fine I'm just like not a real big Marvel
person or I don't really like big temp
hole movies kind of thing so anyway
I really like that he kind of went back
to like a more indie horror type
situation
so the black phone was actually based on
a 2004 short story by Joe Hill who as
pretty much everybody that's watching
this probably knows is Stephen King's
son as well as a best-selling author in
his own right so I will say that the
black phone
does have something of veneer of what
you might call Stephen kinginess you
know what I mean like you got you know
abusive alcoholic dad you got like a
bunch of bullying like you know boys
bullying each other kids with psychic
powers that kind of stuff but it also
kind of also has its own thing going on
and I have to say that I really liked
the whole downbeat 1970s Vibe of it I
think that was one of my favorite things
about it now I will say that the trailer
if you've seen it and like I said if you
went to the movies at all like in late
2021 or early 2022 it was very very hard
to avoid because they showed it all the
time but
um I feel like it gave a lot of the
story away so if you saw the trailer
it's like not it's not gonna be like
super super surprising I think there is
more depth to the movie than what it
showed in the trailer but the movie's
pretty straightforward which actually
was another thing that I kind of liked
about it it wasn't all that complicated
like it was a pretty simple story it was
a pretty straightforward story but it
was done well and it was like had some
depth layers to it but nothing too
abstract or nothing like that so I'm
going to say that even though the
trailer kind of shows how the movie goes
essentially I don't think the movie
overall like suffered as a result of
that I mean because while the movie
isn't really it's not like a masterpiece
or anything like that but as I said it
does have a lot more interesting layers
to it and a better thought out structure
to it than maybe a lot of other
mainstream horror movies do it also went
a little bit darker thematically I think
than I was expecting just in terms of
showing child abuse and bullying in like
a really grounded and very very
realistic kind of way so much so that it
was kind of like uncomfortable to watch
so I feel like Ethan Hawke got most of
the marketing attention uh around this
movie I guess like it's his face on the
poster He's the bad guy and it was kind
of like a big deal because I think prior
to this he'd had kind of a rule where he
didn't play villains so I think as far
as I know this might be the first movie
where he played an out and out villain
like a child killer so I do feel like he
got most of the the marketing thing
because he's the biggest star obviously
but I mean and I'm not going to complain
too much about that because his
performance in this movie is pretty
great but the story here really belongs
to the kid characters and focuses more
on their struggles like Ethan Hawke's
villain like the child killer doesn't
really have as much screen time as they
do and he doesn't even really feature in
the story like to any significant degree
until about 40 minutes in or so like
maybe about halfway I mean and this is a
horror movie sure but to be honest I
kind of feel like it's more properly
classified as maybe like a thriller or
maybe like a dark Coming of Age drama
with horror and Supernatural elements
because there is Supernatural elements
in it it does have horror elements in it
but I don't know if I'd call it like an
out and out horror film but again that's
kind of one of the things that I liked
about it so like don't go into this
expecting it to be like a straight up
slasher flick or anything like that one
review of it I read called it Silence of
the Lambs meet The Sixth Sense which
it's not a perfect comparison but it's
definitely in that same ballpark you
know what I mean so the story is set in
Denver Colorado in 1978 and It Centers
mostly around a boy named finny Blake
who's played by Mason Thames I guess is
how you pronounce his last name even
though I always want to say Thames
because that's how the river is spelled
he has a younger sister named Gwen who's
played by Madeleine McGraw and their
abusive father who's a Miss Terence
who's played by Jeremy Davies now the
dad like his alcoholism and violence
toward his kids have seemed to like they
it's only increased since his wife
committed suicide sometime before I
don't think they specify how long ago it
was but I'm assuming it's fairly fairly
recent so as if the kids don't have it
bad enough like getting their asses
horribly beaten at home they're also the
target of bullies at school and because
this movie is set in the 1970s The
Bullying here like does absolutely go
there I mean these kids like beat the
absolute out of each other and
nobody does anything about it like I
kind of feel like nowadays if kids were
fighting like that like somebody would
intervene you know what I mean like the
parents or School authorities or cops or
somebody like that but nobody does like
it just seems like and that's kind of I
mean I was alive in 1978 so this that
totally does track they were just kind
of like ah the kids they just fight
their own battles you know what I mean
and it's just that kind of so
nobody does anything about it and these
kids are like actually beating the
out of each other now Finney is kind of
friends with this sort of tough kid
whose name is Robin and at one point
Robin like pummels this older
kid like you don't really care because
the kid is a jerk so you're just kind of
like yeah beat his ass whatever but he
just like pummels this kid into
unconsciousness and then just keeps on
beating for good I'm like oh my God is
he gonna beat him to death it was just
it was like that and these are kids you
know what I mean they're probably like
you know 12 13 I don't know I couldn't
tell how old they were uh you know what
I mean and Robin doesn't get any trouble
for this either not that I remember like
in the movie and matter of fact he tells
finny like not long after this incident
like Finney's just kind of like bro like
you know he was very uncomfortable with
how far that fight went he's like I
thought you were gonna kill him he
basically says well you're eventually
gonna have to learn to stand up for
yourself and for others and he basically
says sometimes when it comes to bullies
like you have to draw a lot of blood in
order to make an impression so these
themes of like savagery and cycles of
abuse I mean it's pretty prevalent
throughout the whole movie I wouldn't go
so far as to say it's heavy-handed but
it's definitely not subtle I mean it's
established like almost from the
beginning that Finney's character Arc is
going to involve him having to fight for
survival and learn to ultimately stand
up for himself not only by defeating the
main villain you know the child killer
but also by breaking the cycle of abuse
that's been engendered by his father's
treatment of him and his sister so in
the area where Finney lives there's an
elusive killer who has been nicknamed
the Grabber and he's been snatching boys
off the street and just as would have
happened in 1978 like when you didn't
have the internet and like creepy
like this was going on a bunch of urban
legends have started to spring up about
this killer like including ones that are
kind of more Supernatural in nature like
either there's one point where they say
it's like oh if you say his name like he
can hear you and he'll like come after
you next and stuff like that so while
there is Supernatural stuff going on in
this movie though it's never really made
clear if the killer has any kind of
abilities in that direction I'm thinking
probably no but the victims or at least
Finney and his sister absolutely do
matter of fact Finney's sister Gwen
has dreams that are kind of like Visions
you know what I mean psychic visions and
ever since the abduction started she's
been having these kind of disjointed
nightmares that seem to provide clues
about some of the cases now because she
told the sister of one of the kidnapped
boys that she dreamed about she's like
hey I dreamed about your brother and she
saw some black balloons so the police
actually come to school to question her
because the black balloons thing like
that detail was something they had not
released to the public so they can't
figure out how she knows about it so the
cops actually don't believe her about
her dreams and they're kind of wondering
if she might know more about the crimes
that she's letting on but she claps back
at them like pretty harshly she's just
like oh my God can you really think that
me a little girl I'm just like yeah I'm
the killer you know what I mean she's
like I have dreams you know what I mean
off it's it's really really funny
like actually she's a really really good
uh character matter of fact I think Gwen
actually might be my favorite character
now that I'm thinking about it I mean
she is I can't tell how old she's
supposed to maybe 10 but she's just this
smart mouth swearing little badass and
she is absolutely not afraid to stand
her ground and like tell people to their
faces that they're full of so like
in that way she's kind of like a
Counterpoint to her brother who is kind
of more subdued and fearful and he
desperately wants to intervene when he
sees other people being hurt such as his
sister but he's afraid to whereas Gwen
uh she will absolutely jump right into
the mix like her brother is getting
beaten up and she jumps right in there
and she gets her ass kicked too by a
bunch of boys which like I said totally
would have happened in 1978 so it's hard
to watch but it's pretty realistic so
she's absolutely not afraid of getting
her ass beat you know what I mean and
her dad actually usually beats her up
specifically for talking about her
psychic abilities because they remind
him of his late wife who apparently also
had dreams of this nature um which may
have been a factor in her suicide so
obviously he's he doesn't want to be
reminded of that and it like you know
puts him into a rage so he will like
just wail on that little girl which is
like horrible I mean there's one scene
that's like fairly early on in the movie
where Gwen's dad just like whips the
out of her and it's like it's
brutal and it's like really real and
it's really like upsetting to watch and
I mean like the acting work is good all
around in this but Madeleine McGraw and
Jeremy Davies in that scene are
absolutely incredible I mean you
actually buy that I mean I was really
uncomfortable it was really
uncomfortable for me to watch because it
just seemed like it was so genuine so
the Grabber who he basically all they
know about him is that he's like an
amateur magician or he like drives a
black fan or something so he snatches a
few kids off the street including
finny's friend Robin who's like the
toughest kid in school now Finney is
actually really horrified by this
because he figures hey if Robin could be
taken who is like the toughest kid in
school then anybody could you know what
I mean and at this point in the movie
which is about I want to say it's maybe
about halfway through maybe like a
little bit less
um after all of this character setup has
been done because you were like the
first 40 45 minutes of the movie is
basically like setup of the kids you
know what I mean you don't really see
much of the Grabber it's like you kind
of see like the van and it's like you
know a kid going like oh there's the van
over there and then that kid disappears
and so there's that kind of stuff so
there's a lot of character build up with
the kids so I'm just saying that it's
like don't go into it expecting this to
be child killer all the time because he
doesn't show up until like the halfway
point
so um so yeah about the halfway point uh
the inevitable happens and Finney is
himself captured by the Grabber uh who
throws him into a yucky basement with
only a bed and there's also like a
non-functional black phone title drop
hanging on the wall now the grabber's
interest in the boys that he takes
doesn't seem overtly sexual like he's
not a child molester not in the classic
sense and if I could use that
terminology what a weird way to put it
but in parallel with Finney's own father
the Grabber it seems like feels the need
to punish the children for their
transgressions like he's sort of playing
a game that he calls naughty boy or like
Naughty Boys
um in essence what he'll do is he'll
leave like Avenues of Escape like kind
of obviously open to the boys and he it
seems like he does it out of like
carelessness but it's all part of this
game like he actually wants the boys to
try and Escape he wants them to try and
misbehave so he can beat them and kill
them so he can punish them essentially
and perhaps feel justified in doing so I
felt like that was implicit um they
don't really say that I mean the Grabber
is actually never given a backstory now
some reviewers liked that and some
didn't because some were like well I
kind of wish they'd said you know what's
with the magician thing and why is he
doing what he's doing and what's with
that but I tend to fall on the side of
liking that his background was kept
almost entirely a mystery because I
think it made him creepier and it made
you as the viewer have to deal with the
killer on the same terms as his victims
would because his victims wouldn't know
this or nothing like that
so you know there so there was that so I
think it's better like that you didn't
know anything about why he was doing
what he was doing
like there were some little hints given
as to why the Grabber was the way he was
like for example the rotating series of
masks that he wears to convey his moods
those Max masks were designed by us Tom
savini by the way which uh they actually
are really really good but that's kind
of all they are is hints and I actually
thought this made the movie stronger
because you know if anybody that's
that's been around here a long time
knows I'm a big advocate of not over
explaining your villain like or your
monster like it's scarier the less you
know about them usually not always there
are exceptions to that but I think
generally it's a good rule to follow now
once Finney realizes what's happened
he's been taken by the Grabber he's in
this basement he almost immediately
becomes like resigned to his fate like
he's like if none of the other boys
escaped like then what chance do I have
type of thing but soon enough the
supernatural intervenes the non-working
ostensibly a black phone on the wall
starts to ring and when Finney answers
it he starts getting messages from
essentially like the ghosts of the boys
that have been murdered before him and
they tell him about their own
experiences their own uh you know things
that happen to them like ways they tried
to escape like this works this didn't
work like avoid this doing this avoid
doing that
um and they kind of just like give him
general advice on how to survive and how
to get out of there
now meanwhile while that's all going on
Gwen is deliberately trying to have
visions that will save her brother but
for a long time like her prayers go
unanswered because she's like praying to
Jesus it's kind of like funny like it's
sad but it's kind of funny too at the
same time she's like praying to Jesus to
like ever she's like man you're giving
me all these like Visions about like
other people but when it's my brother
like he can't give me anything but when
she does finally start to have dreams
about him the details are just like
really sketchy and it's like really
frustrating but eventually she starts to
piece together enough I guess like
actionable information to take to the
cops and the cops like actually slowly
start to take her gift more seriously
because she does seem to know what she's
talking about and some of her like
checks out so as I mentioned I mean the
black phone it's not the best horror
movie ever um and it's not even
particularly scary I mean it's creepy
for sure but it's not like frightening
or like overtly horror like the way
maybe Sinister was but it's a pretty
solid
um dark drama like with a horror flavor
I guess Ethan Hawke is really great like
as the Grabber he's very very unsettling
he's very menacing and he's also kind of
like socially awkward which makes him
even more creepy you know what I mean
and he almost never shows his face
because he almost always has like a mask
or like part of a mask over it which I
think was really was really cool uh the
kid actors in This most of them are
phenomenal and that actually goes a long
way toward you kind of getting on their
side and like rooting for them to escape
and stuff like that and actually like
the end like with the reunited like the
brother and sister and everything like
that I just I kind of like choked up a
little bit it was like really really
well done and as I mentioned I feel like
the structure of the movie is actually
really well considered like drawing
parallels between Finney's abuse at the
hands of his dad and his bullies and you
know his growth toward finding the Inner
Strength necessary it to defeat the
Grabber in the end so it's kind of like
a coming-of-age story in that way so
like I said uh the movie also just kind
of looks cool it has that kind of like
dower 70s vibe to it
um and it also has much like Sinister
had it had that those kind of like
inserts of like super eight but in this
instance uh the Super 8 it's almost kind
of used it's used to um to show Gwen's
Visions so it gives it that little bit
of like unreality or surreality which uh
which really looks kind of cool I think
probably the only thing I didn't love
was the addition of the character of Max
there was nothing wrong with like the
actor or anything like that but I just
thought he was a little too over the top
like a little too comic relief kind of
he wasn't in it much but I could have
done without that but I don't know it
didn't bother me all that much but I'm
gonna say like while I I liked the movie
Just Fine while I was watching it but I
think like thinking about it afterward
gave me a little bit of like a deeper
appreciation of the themes that it was
uh putting across and like the way that
a plot was constructed so I think I
ended up liking it even more in
retrospect than it did while I was
watching it if that makes any sense so
that will do it for this flickers of
fear thank you very much for watching
Remember remember to like and share and
please comment if you enjoyed the
content and I will see you guys again on
the next one bye
[Music]
expires
and darkness and decay
[Music]
foreign